[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Sirin Ihnen allen einen schönen
guten Abend Katja später mit dem Blick
auf den vorläufigen WM Kader der
Fußballfrauen ja in 50 Tagen ist schönen
guten Abend und hier sind unsere Themen
diplomatischer Paukenschlag vier von
fünf russischen generalkonsulaten in
Deutschland müssen schließen
deutliches Urteil die linksextremistin
Lina e muss wegen Angriffen auf Neonazis
mehr als fünf Jahre hinter Gitter
kaum noch Tabak Qualm Schweden wird wohl
in diesem Jahr als erstes Land der Welt
auch frei werden
[Musik]
wir beginnen die Sendung mit einem
diplomatischen donnerhalt die
Bundesregierung entzieht vier russischen
generalkonsulaten in Deutschland die
Lizenz es ist die drastische Antwort auf
die Entscheidung Moskau die Zahl
deutscher offizieller in Russland zu
begrenzen das wird ja unter anderem zu
Schließung deutscher Konsulate deren
Mitarbeiter Russland verlassen müssen
mehr zur diplomatischen Eskalation von
Andreas Kühnast
an der Deutschen Schule in Moskau ist
man Kameras Beobachtung ist man alle
möglichen Formen von Ärger gewohnt aber
ab jetzt geht es um die Existenz weil
das russische Außenministerium nun auch
den Abzug von deutschsprachigen Lehrern
Kindergärtnern sogar ortskräften
erreichen will muss Deutschland
plötzlich die Zahl seiner in Russland
Beschäftigten auf maximal 350 senken
damit ist die russische Regierung einen
Schritt der Eskalation gegangen und
diese ungerechtfertigte Entscheidung
zwingt die Bundesregierung zu einem sehr
erheblichen Einschnitt in allen
Bereichen ihrer Präsenz in Russland
Deutschland kann neben seiner Botschaft
in Moskau jetzt nur noch das
Generalkonsulat in St Petersburg
aufrecht erhalten die Standorte
Kaliningrad Jekaterinburg und
Novosibirsk müssen geschlossen werden
als Gegenmaßnahme verlangt Berlin dass
die russische Botschaft 4 ihrer fünf
Generalkonsulate in Deutschland schließt
welche bleibt Russland überlassen
schon die bisherigen Ausweisungen waren
so folgenreich so aufgeladen dass
russische Sicherheitskräfte jedes Bild
davon verhindern wollten obwohl Russland
seit jeher viel mehr Personal
beschäftigt und damit weniger zu
verlieren hatte die Tatsache dass die
Vertretung Russlands in Deutschlands
sehr viel größer waren immer als die
Deutschlands im Ausland hängt schlicht
damit zusammen dass Russland stets ihre
seine eigenen Vertretung unendlich mit
Mitarbeitern der Geheimdienste
vollgestopfter kann man gar nicht anders
sagen was übrigens die russische Seite
interessanterweise am Ende auch immer
eingeräumt hat die deutsche Schule in
Moskau will die Bundesregierung offen
halten und möglichst viele diplomatische
Kanäle auch aber es werden immer weniger
zur Einordnung nach Berlin zu Theo Koll
also Theos ist es weitere Kappen
diplomatischer Verbindung wie ist das
einzuschätzen also damit werden auf
beiden Seiten noch verbliebene Brücken
gesperrt bzw sogar eingerissen besonders
hart trifft es dabei übrigens die
deutsche Seite den russland hat für die
personelle gesamtpräsenz Deutschlands in
Russland ja die eben erwähnte Obergrenze
von 350 gesetzt das bedeutet aber
ungefähr eine Halbierung des deutschen
Personals denn es werden nicht nur die
deutsche Botschaft sondern auch
Konsulate Stiftungen deutsche Schulen
Kindergärten und Goethe Institute
mitgezählt einschließlich der russischen
ortskräfte und die Zahl 350 die hatte
Russland nicht zufällig gewählt sondern
sie entspricht der russischen
Personalstärke hier in Deutschland
zumindest der offiziellen Deutschland
verlangt jetzt zwar die Schließung von
vier der fünf Generalkonsulate die
Gesamtzahl des russischen Personals darf
aber so bleiben das heißt es ist
eigentlich ein Gegenschlag mit weich
gepolstertem Handschuh und dennoch hat
Russlands Außenministerium weitere
Gegenmaßnahmen sofort angekündigt
insgesamt ist diese Eskalation dennoch
eine extrem bedauerliche Entwicklung
denn jede Eiszeit hat ja hoffentlich
eine Zeit danach und da müssen auch die
diplomatischen und
zivilgesellschaftlichen Brücken erst
wieder neu gebaut werden für diese
Einordnung vielen Dank nach Berlin
zum Ukraine Krieg nach dem
aufsehenerregenden Drohnenangriff auf
Moskau meldet Russlands Armee jetzt dass
man das letzte große Kriegsschiff der
ukrainischen Seestreitkräfte zerstört
habe weiterhin gibt es viele Angriffe
aber das ukrainische Militär verteidigt
nicht nur sondern befindet sich auch in
der Vorwärtsbewegung Volker Duce
das hier ist die Front das Dorf heißt
karparty russisch besetztes Gebiet nahe
Johannes hier sollen ukrainische
Artillerie Geschosse eingeschlagen sein
sagen die von Moskau eingesetzten
Behörden mindestens vier Tote 16
Verletzte aus Kiew dazu kein Kommentar
die ukrainische Seite versucht ganz
offenbar seit Wochen durch gezielte
Angriffe auf die kritische Infrastruktur
also etwa Treibstoff und Munitionsdepots
die russischen Nachschubwege in Richtung
von zu stören beobachter vermuten dass
das der Vorbereitung einer
möglicherweise bevorstehenden Offensive
dienen könnte
im zweiten Jahr des Krieges wird der
russische Aggressor selbst zunehmen zur
Zielscheibe unweit von krassen und da
ganz im Süden Russlands brennt erneut
eine große Ölraffinerie die Anlage nach
fipski eine zweite Raffinerie 20 km
entfernt steht ebenfalls in Flammen
wichtige Produktion Stätten für
Treibstoff beide Ziel von Drohnen
Angaben über Tote und Verletzte gibt es
nicht
die Ziele von Angriffen sind anders als
gestern bei den Drohnen Attacken auf
Moskau nicht weit von der ukrainischen
Grenze entfernt die Wirtschaftsmetropole
krassen odal im Süden schebekino bei
Belgorod direkt hinter der russischen
Grenze nahe dem ukrainischen haarkiff
auf der russischen Seite brennen Autos
von Artillerie getroffen sind auch
Wohngebiete Moskau beschuldigt auch hier
die Ukraine die Ukraine widerspricht
auch hier
wir gehen jetzt zum Treffen der
NATO-Außenminister nach Oslo florian
neuhahn ist für uns dabei Florian die
jüngsten Attacken auf russisches Gebiet
die sind dort auch Thema was sagt die
NATO
na erstmal relativ wenig das Thema ist
schließlich wirklich heikel für die NATO
so wenig so heikel dass die Gastgeberin
dieses Treffens die norwegische
Außenministerin anikin weedfeld hier
vorhin auf der eröffnungspressekonferenz
auf meine Frage danach gar nichts
antworten wollte sie wolle ja Sie können
das nicht kommentieren weil es schlicht
keine verlässlichen Informationen dazu
gebe was ist aber gibt das ist eine
ziemlich deutliche Warnung an die
Adresse der Ukraine und zwar von den USA
von der US nato-botschafterin im
US-amerikanischen Fernsehen dort sagte
sie man dürfen nicht die gelieferten
Waffen für Angriffe auf russisches
Territorium nutzen also die NATO wird
sich hier noch einmal deutlich an die
Seite der Ukraine stellen aber eben auch
klar machen dass sie eine solche
Eskalation nicht will und sollte das die
neue Strategie der Ukraine sein mit
Betonung auf sollte ja dann wäre das
wirklich ein Spiel mit dem Feuer
live aus aus vielen Dank Florian
jetzt zum Urteil in einem der größten
linksextremismusprozesse seit Jahren es
geht um die 28-Jährige Studentin Lina
sie wurde zu mehr als fünf Jahren Haft
verurteilt weil sie als Kopf einer
Gruppe Angriffe auf Neonazis plante und
mit durchführte verurteilte und
Sympathisanten sehen sich weiter
moralisch im Recht im Kampf gegen
Rechtsextremismus Franziska wunderlich
berichtet
wie ein Star wird Lina e von ihren
Anhängern bejubelt als sie den
Sitzungssaal betritt nach 97
Verhandlungstagen fällt der Richter am
Morgen sein Urteil fünf Jahre und drei
Monate Haft für Lina e zwischen knapp
zweieinhalb und dreieinhalb Jahren für
die mit Angeklagten das Urteil heute hat
eine sehr starke Signalwirkung deswegen
glaube ich dass meine Mitarbeiter und
Mitarbeiter im Landeskriminalamt dem
polizeilichen terrorismusabwehrzentrum
jetzt durchschnaufen und morgen
weitermachen weil wir haben so viel
Ansatzpunkte für weiterführende
Ermittlungen das war noch nicht das Ende
aufgrund der bisherigen Ermittlungen saß
der Richter als erwiesen anders Lina e
Mitglied eine kriminellen Vereinigung
war die systematisch Jagd auf
rechtsextreme machte zwischen Oktober
2018 und Februar 2020 verletzte die
Gruppe um Lina e 13 Menschen in Sachsen
und Thüringen so schlugen sie einen
Bekannten Neonazi aus Wurzen
krankenhausreif eine anderen Person
brachten sie Jochbein und Schädelknochen
die Überfälle waren geplant und eine Art
Vergeltungsschlag nach rechten
Übergriffen
diese radikalisierungs- und
Gewaltspirale darf sich nicht weiter
steigern unsere Sicherheitsbehörden
haben die gewaltbereiten
linksextremistischen Szenen genau im
Blick und werden weiter konsequent
handeln in einem demokratischen
Rechtsstaat darf es keinen Raum für
Selbstjustiz geben die
Staatsanwaltschaft hatte sogar acht
Jahre für Lina e gefordert doch die
Beweiskette war brüchig Aussagen waren
widersprüchlich die Verteidigung
plädierte auf Freispruch den wollten
auch die Anhänger der linken Szene und
haben bereits massive Proteste
angekündigt bis hin zur Androhung von
Gewalt und Zerstörung
der Bundesanwaltschaft ist offenbar ein
Schlag gegen einen Finanzierungsnetzwerk
der terrormiliz islamischer Staat
gelungen bei einer großrazieher in 10
Bundesländern haben Ermittler sieben
mutmaßliche is-anhänger festgenommen und
mehr als 100 Objekte durchsucht die
Verdächtigen sollen Spendengelder für is
Frauen in Syrien gesammelt haben drei
der Hauptverdächtigen sitzen
mittlerweile in Untersuchungshaft
schlechte Nachricht für Bahnreisende und
Pendler im tarifstrahl bei der Deutschen
Bahn hat die Gewerkschaft EVG mit
weiteren Streiks gedroht möglicherweise
abkommender Woche zuvor hatte die EVG
ein Bahnangebot zurückgewiesen und zu
erneuten Verhandlungen aufgerufen die
Bahn lehnte weitere Gespräche aber ab
Streitpunkt sind vor allem die Gehälter
der unteren Lohngruppen für sie fordert
die Gewerkschaft deutlich mehr Geld
es ist eine Zahl die Verbrauchern
Hoffnung macht die Inflationsrate in
Deutschland ist deutlich gesunken die
lag nämlich im November vergangenen
Jahres noch bei 8,8 Prozent jetzt ist
sie nach vorläufigen Zahlen für den Mai
auf 6,1% gesunken im Vergleich zum
Vorjahresmonat damit ist die
Preissteigerung immer noch hoch aber die
Richtung die zeigt nach unten Benzin und
Heizöl etwa wurden günstiger und auch
der rasante Preisanstieg bei
Lebensmitteln der schlechte sich
immerhin etwas ab wir gehen nach
Frankfurt an die Börse zu Frank Beet man
fragt die Inflationsrate wir haben es
gerade gesagt singt auf
1,6,1% ist aber trotzdem noch hoch ist
das jetzt die Trendwende dafür ist es
noch ein bisschen zu früh denn in
einigen Bereichen bleibt der Preisdruck
hoch Pauschalreisen verteilten sich
beispielsweise enorm und mit Blick auf
die anstehende Urlaubssaison und der
Erwartung dass viele Deutsche dann doch
trotz knapper Kassen auf Ihren Urlaub
nicht verzichten wollen
fürchten Ökonomen da könnte noch was
kommen die Inflationsrate könnte sich im
Sommer möglicherweise noch mal in
Richtung sieben Prozent bewegen und so
ist klar der Weg zurück zur normalen
Preisen wird ein langer sein das sehen
wir insbesondere an den Nahrungsmitteln
die im Mai zwar weniger stark als noch
im April zulegten aber sich immer noch
um 14,9% verteuerten ähnliche
Entwicklung bei den Dienstleistungen ein
weniger starker Anstieg jedoch immer
noch einer von viereinhalb Prozent
insgesamt gehen die Experten weiterhin
davon aus dass die durchschnittliche
Teuerung in diesem Jahr irgendwo
zwischen fünf und sechs Prozent liegen
wird und damit deutlich über so mancher
Lohnerhöhung was nichts anderes bedeutet
in vielen Haushalten wird in diesem Jahr
weiter kräftig gespart werden müssen
vielen Dank und Grüße nach Frankfurt
die Inflation singt also belastet aber
weiter die Wirtschaft Arbeitslose haben
gerade eher schlechtere Aussichten auf
einen Job zwar gegen die Zahl der
Arbeitslosen im Mai zurück aber weniger
stark als üblich laut Bundesagentur für
Arbeit sind zwei Millionen 544
000 Menschen ohne Job
42.000 weniger als im April die Quote
sind leicht auf 5,5 %. Vergleich zum
vergangenen Jahr sind 284
000 Menschen mehr arbeitslos
wer Arbeit hat der möchte gerecht
entlohnt werden Leiharbeiter kritisieren
dass sie weniger verdienen als
Stammbeschäftigte obwohl sie das gleiche
leisten das Bundesarbeitsgericht hat
heute entschieden Leiharbeiter dürfen
tatsächlich schlechter bezahlt werden
wenn sie dafür andere Vorteile erhalten
die das Ausgleichen sarattacke mit mehr
zum Thema
sie arbeitet als Produktionshelferin in
einem werkzeugbauunternehmen in
Rheinland-Pfalz Nina Erhard ist dort
aber nicht direkt beschäftigt sondern
über eine Zeitarbeitsfirma und wird nach
eigener Aussage deshalb schlechter
bezahlt als ihre regulär Beschäftigten
Kollegen
ich mache dieselbe Arbeit wie jede
andere dort auch ich übernehme die
gleiche Verantwortung wie jeder andere
Mitarbeiter dort auch
natürlich fragt man sich dann oder sagt
man sich dann halt das wäre auch schön
wenn man dann noch dementsprechend das
gleiche verdienen würde mehr als 800.000
Menschen arbeiten in Deutschland aktuell
als Leiharbeiter und Leiharbeiter
bekommen bei gleicher Arbeitsleistung im
Schnitt 40% weniger Lohn als regulär
Beschäftigte das geht auch in Ordnung
legten die Richter nun Richter am
Bundesarbeitsgericht heute in einem
Grundsatzurteil fest geklagt hatte eine
Frau die als Leiharbeiterin bei H&M
beschäftigt war
die Klägerin hat keinen Anspruch auf ein
Arbeitsentgelt wie es vergleichbare
stammarbeitnehmer das Entleihers
erhalten haben das Argument des Gerichts
Leiharbeitnehmer sein gesetzlich
ausreichend abgesichert denn sie werden
fortlaufend bezahlt auch wenn sie gar
nicht eingesetzt sind das gleiche die
schlechte Bezahlung aus ich bedauere das
Urteil wir haben es nicht geschafft den
Gleichbehandlungsgrundsatz durchzusetzen
für Leiharbeiter
Lohn für gleiche Arbeit darauf hat sie
erst einen Anspruch wenn sie regulär
beschäftigt wird
heute ist Welt nichtrauchertag für uns
anders mal auf die Zahlen in Deutschland
und Europa zu schauen in der EU da
konsumieren etwa 25 Prozent der
Bevölkerung regelmäßig Tabak in
Deutschland liegt der Anteil der Raucher
mit 34 Prozent deutlich darüber muss das
Schüler ist Schweden da Rauchen nur noch
5,6 Prozent des Land könnte als erstes
in Europa die fünf Prozentmarke knacken
und so den Status rauchfrei erhalten
Claas Thomsen
Rauchen in der Öffentlichkeit in
Schweden ein eher ungewöhnliches Bild
auf dem Weg zu einem Land das als erstes
offiziell als rauchfrei gilt das macht
viele Schwedinnen und Schweden schon ein
wenig stolz ich finde rauchfreies
Schweden das klingt klug es ist gut dass
sie eingeführt haben dass man nicht auf
Terrassen und vor den Bars rauchen darf
oder drinnen
ich hasse Rauchen ich bin gegen
jegliches Rauchen ich finde es unnötig
gleichzeitig finde ich aber wenn jemand
rauchen will habe ich nichts dagegen ich
finde das sehr gut in meiner Generation
Rauchen nur sehr wenige die meisten
Leute nehmen stattdessen
das sind meistens nikotinhaltige
Tabakbeutel die man sich in die Backe
schiebt die sind Schweden
traditionsreiche Alternative zum Rauchen
hat im Stricken verboten und der
gesellschaftlichen Ächtung viel zum
Rückgang des Rauchens beigetragen es
gilt als gesundheitlich unbedenklicher
und Nichtraucher werden nicht behelligt
allerdings süchtig kann es auch machen
aus meiner Sicht als Realist ist das
aber ganz okay wenn wir dafür Produkte
haben die keinen krebserzeugen und keine
Atemwegserkrankung doch wie
gesundheitsschädlich Alternativen wie
süß oder E-Zigaretten wirklich sind und
ob sie einen Einstieg in den Tabakkonsum
sind ist umstritten Nikotinsucht wird so
auch in Schweden weiter diskutiert
werden
wenn Sie mit dem Rauchen aufhören wollen
dann könnte sich ein Blick in unsere
heute App lohnen da zeigen wir Ihnen wie
schnell sich Ihr Körper entgiften würde
mit den ersten positiven Effekten schon
nach einem halben Tag und sie sehen in
welcher Reihenfolge sich Geschmackssinn
Herz oder Lunge erholen
so wir sind beim Sport Katja in 50 Tagen
am 20 Juli geht's los Frauen Fußball
Weltmeisterschaft in Australien und
Neuseeland und heute ist der vorläufige
WM Kader bekannt gegeben worden von der
Bundestrainerin genau Martina Voss
Tecklenburg hat 28 Namen verkündet nicht
mit dabei Julia gewinnt der 23-Jährigen
Abwehrspielerin fehle es nach ihrem
zweiten Kreuzbandriss an Spielpraxis für
die Bundestrainerin die schwierigste
aber eine Vernunftsentscheidung sagt sie
dafür ist Melanie leupolz von einem FC
Chelsea zurück 8 Monate nach der Geburt
ihres ersten Kindes
seit Jahren schon ist die
Mittelfeldspielerin eine feste Größe und
in einem Team ohne Melanie leupolz würde
irgendetwas fehlenholz ist da total
reflektiert was das ganze Thema angeht
das ist schön dass wir das mittlerweile
machen können dass wir unsere
fußballspielenden Mütter in der Form
unterstützen können
Kapitänin Alexandra Popp in der
Sturmspitze wird ihr Team wieder
anführen und ihren unbändigen Elan auf
den ganzen Kader übertragen für
Missstimmung sorgte der FC Bayern der
gestern mitteilte dass er seine fünf
Spielerinnen erst drei Tage nach dem
vereinbarten Termin für das
Trainingslager freistellt der Zeitpunkt
ist einfach
erschreckend und teilweise wurden dann
auch willkürlich Daten dann irgendwann
mal in den Gesprächen in den Raum
geschmissen das Team wird in zwei
Trainingslagern gut vorbereitet nach
Australien fliegen damit sich Bilder wie
bei der EM im vorigen Jahr auch Down
Under wiederholen
ja und der VfB Stuttgart und der
Hamburger SV müssen Nachsitzen
respektive spielen Relegation ist da
Stichwort wer spielt kommende Saison
erstklassig die Stuttgarter jedenfalls
sind trotz einer chaos-saison durchaus
zuversichtlich
bislang ist es nur ein frommer Wunsch
aber sie waren der zweiten Liga mit
Trainer Hoeneß schon mal ziemlich nahe
stehen im Vergleich dazu jetzt gerade zu
glänzend da als ich hier begonnen habe
war mein Platz 18 und da war wirklich
hier und da zu hören jetzt nicht
unbedingt aus der Mannschaft aber hier
und da zu hören dass das
himmelfahrtkommando ist ja dass die die
Chance sehr sehr gering ist dass man das
noch packt und trotzdem und jetzt sind
wir auf Platz 16 haben sie in der Hand
das zu packen auf ihren angeschlagenen
Torwart Fabian retlo werden Sie
eventuell verzichten müssen Stuttgart
Optimismus bremst das nicht schon gar
nicht den von Trainerin ist
morgen denn das erste Spiel sind
gespannt vielen Dank Katja wir schauen
jetzt noch auf die Lottozahlen hier sind
sie 22 30 35 39 41 45 und die Superzahl
lautet 6 weitere Gewinnzahlen auf
lotto.zdf.de und auf der ZDF Text Seite
warm und sonnig morgen zum
meteorologischen Sommeranfang Details
hat gleich Christa oben das heute
journal mit Dunja Hayali ab 21:45 Uhr
morgen an dieser Stelle wieder Jana
paralkes schönen Dank schönen Abend auf
bald
[Musik]
guten Abend das war heute der letzte
Frühlingstag morgen beginnt der
meteorologische Sommer und das war ein
Tag voller Sonne wie hier am
Timmendorfer Strand an der Ostsee
übrigens gab es in diesem Frühling die
meiste Sonne zwischen 600 und 700
Stunden hier gab es nämlich oft
Hochdruckeinfluss und auch im Moment
haben wir dieses Hoch Viola das uns im
Moment in ganz Deutschland stabile
sonnige Tage beschert morgen schummelt
sich allerdings eine schwache Kaltfront
in den Norden des Landes die wird dann
zwar kein Regen mitbringen aber doch
recht dichte Wolken und die erreichen
schon in den Frühstunden der Nacht den
Norden des Landes sonst ist es oft klar
der klare Himmel sorgt für Abkühlung die
Werte sinken auf 13 bis 6 Grad aber es
gibt keinen Bodenfrost mehr den kühlen
Tagen stehen sehr den kühlen Nächten
stehen sehr warme Tage gegenüber die
Werte Morgen meist zwischen 20 und 28
Grad am Oberrhein nur im Nordwesten das
ist mit 14 bis 19 Grad doch deutlich
kühler und das liegt eben an den Wolken
die die Sonneneinstrahlung hier dämpfen
außerdem dreht hinter der Kaltfront auch
der Nordwestwind der der Wind auf
Nordwest und da gibt's dann einen
lebhaften Seewind ansonsten ist das
morgen ein Tag für Sonnenliebhaber nur
abends gibt's ein paar Gewitter aus den
Alpen heraus und mit diesem sonnigen und
warmen Wetter geht es bis zum Wochenende
weiter tschüss